[Musique]
on est venu pour voir Lucie boyton ce
soir c'est toujours bien de venir de
faire découvrir des films découvrir des
acteurs aussi parfois qui passent sur le
tapis rouge mais qui sont méconnus puis
je me dis je me dis un jour peut-être
que j'aimerais bien être sur le tapis
aussi parce que j'aimerais bien être
actrice alors voilà je suis venue avec
ma mère on a l'habitude de venir parce
que
Deauville on connaît bien et puis on est
des grandes fans de cinéma donc ça nous
touche ça nous parle quoi les films de
demain m'intéressent beaucoup notamment
Watchers Ghost country aussi que
j'attends beaucoup voilà aussi le
nouveau film de Jesse Eisenberg ce qui
est sympa c'est donc de la fin de lors
de la journée de courir un peu entre les
trois et cinéma de Deauville et de
passer la journée vraiment de 9 heures à
22h au cinéma quoi c'est ça qu'on aime
bien
[Musique]
cette sélection elle est faite pour
servir le cinéma et en servant le cinéma
on serre un arbre si je devais définir
un festival de Deauville je pense que je
lirai c'est le festival qui écrit
l'avenir l'avenir des émotions des
spectateurs l'avenir de la découverte
[Musique]
indépendants américains en Europe et
donc Deauville est vraiment l'endroit où
c'est cinéma indépendant américain peut
être promu peut être remontré trouver
des distributeurs et trouver un
règlement le cinéma américain nous donne
toujours des nouvelles des nouvelles du
monde et des nouvelles de l'Amérique et
donc c'est formidable
[Musique]